in removing the controls that you would
have to have even with a completely
deregulated environment namely you have
to have the examiner's going into the
banks to assure the public the public
interest in having them safely run
because the public does not have access
to information about the real condition
of banks only the examiners have the
authority to go in and see if the loan
portfolios are good or if the money is
being wasted and what happened in the
early 80s and I think this was the fault
of ideological confusion in removing the
market controls over the kinds of
investments the banks and the SNL's
could make the government also cut down
the number of examiners who are there to
protect the public it's the I think
equivalent to the meat market if you you
could deregulate price controls on meat
but you still need the meat inspectors
in the in the butcheries as this
situation has unfolded has the Bush
administration added examiner's back to
the regulatory agencies to try to check
this situation well actually that began
in 1984-85 when in the case of the SNL's
the Bank board under Edie gray started
moving examiner's into the the district
banks so that they could get out from
under the controls that were being
imposed by the Office of Management and
Budget but I think that's where the
second level of the of the crisis began
and that was political interference so
you had both a mistaken implementation
of deregulation and you had very serious
political interference from members of
Congress as well as members of the White
House staff in your preface talking
about that political interference you
say criminals who plundered the banks
and thrifts got away with it because
they could buy political protection how
do they go about doing it well it's
actually a very neat arrangement if
you're a criminal when you get control
of a bank you have access to the
depositors money you'll rake off a bit
of the money in campaign contributions
which gives you access to a congressman
and the five senators we've heard a lot
about the heating five jim wright and
tony coelho and can call on them when
the examiners start bearing down on you
and when that happens you have a closed
loop and the public is public interest
is sacrificed this is yesterday's
Washington Post the front page FBI
probing senators role in aiding savings
and loan that's the headline I'm going
to drop this now to read the first
paragraph the FBI last week began an
investigation of the role of five
senators intervening with regulators in
1987 on behalf of Arizona financial
executive Charles Keating it was Charles
Keating Charles Keating is a fascinating
character he's a beanpole of a person
five six foot five a lean piercing blue
eyes notice and smile he's the owner of
Lincoln Savings and Loan in California
which he owns there was holding company
American continental corporation and he
probably more than anyone else in the
business has made made a practice of
campaign contributions millions of
dollars to at least 36 prominent
politicians
this is today's Washington Times with
the studies roll of the five centers and
Savings and Loan negotiations who are
the Senators involved in this particular
investigation
well the Keating five our senators
Cranston from California Deakin Seanie
and McCain from Arizona
Don regal from Michigan and by forgotten
one know I think that that covers it I
see we also have John Glenn from Ohio I
don't forget him what what was their
relationship with mr. Keating uh they
all received large campaign
contributions Cranston alone received
about a million dollars uh some of it
personal some of it indirectly to get
out the vote campaigns this morning's
Washington Post there's a editorial mr.
Keating senators and begins this way the
worst thing about the Lincoln Savings
and Loan case may not be that five
senators been implicated did break
Senate rules but that they didn't that
the rules are so tolerant seamy behavior
that what was done in this instance
falls within them rather than without
them what are the rules in the Senate
regarding the situation are the rules to
lacs
well I think that point is right on the
mark in fact a turning point a very
dangerous precedent was set in the House
Ethics Committee when it was
investigating Jim Wright Speaker of the
House
who would intervene for several Texas
threats that were outright criminal
operations and they decided not to bring
charges against him based on his
intervention on behalf of the SNL's they
said that was consistent with the
standards of congressional conduct and
I'm afraid that as the editorial says
that's an extremely dangerous precedent
that the standards really have been
lowered and the people in Congress
really don't seem to realize what damage
they've done to the financial system
good morning welcome to our program this
morning we're spending the next 45
minutes talking about the savings and
loan situation with author and
journalist James Adams he's written a
book about the situation it's called the
big fix inside the Savings and Loan
scandal we invite you to join in our
discussion as usual you'll see the
numbers at the bottom of your screen -
OH - six - eight - 525 for our callers
in the eastern and central time zone and
202 783 - seven - seven for our viewers
in the Pacific and mountain time zones
if you called in the past 30 days we ask
you to please wait it gives more people
an opportunity to phone in with their
questions and comments our guest is
James Adam sees a journalist who's
covered banking for The Wall Street
Journal in Barron's and the American
Spectator previously wrote for the
editorial pages of the Wall Street
Journal for 13 years and was senior
editor for Forbes and he's also the
author of the secret history of the tax
revolt his BA from Yale and an MA and
PhD in government from Cornell how open
were people in the business in talking
to you about this for writing your book
was it easy to get information I found
that they were very cooperative both
businessmen and regulators in fact a lot
of people were very eager to get the
story known because it's been simmering
for a long time it's been festering and
a lot of people have been frustrated by
not being able to get through to the
public about how really dangerous the
situation had gotten you say that in the
book you focus on two fellows William
Isaac and Edwin gray who are they
William Isaac was chairman of the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
which insures commercial banks about
13,000 Edwin Gray was the chairman of
the Federal Home Loan Bank board from
1983 to 1987 and they were in charge of
the Savings and Loan
those are the institutions that
supposedly make home loan mortgages and
allowed millions of people to to own
their homes in the last 40 years he
really took the brunt of the S&L crisis
and it was vilified for his attempts to
try to bring things under control and
instill it were there efforts or how
were their efforts hindered by the
administration by this.d supervision I
in the case of Ed gray the it took him a
few months to realize how serious the
crisis had grown and when they started
turning up widespread fraud particularly
in the texas institutions i
he was extremely short-handed and went
consistently to OMB Management and
Budget and to the White House to get
more staff and was consistently rebuffed
in fact people were telling him that
that's not the point of this
administration that we should be taking
government off the backs of the
entrepreneurs well there was some
confusion there because the
entrepreneurs were still getting a
massive federal subsidy in the form of
deposit insurance and in fact had opened
a back door to the Treasury but it took
him years really to try to get things
under control and as he tightened up on
supervision it began to run into a
ferocious political resistance from
Congress and from Don Regan chief of
staff at the White House we have lines
open for our callers out west our first
call this morning's from Baltimore good
morning good morning first let me
compliment you on I think you're doing a
marvelous job when bringing the bringing
this issue to the Sun as mr. gray likes
to say first of all why do we have to
have two regulatory agencies one for the
commercial bank and one for the S&L
aren't don't they basically do the same
thing thanks for the call Baltimore well
they are tending toward doing the same
thing as the last 10 years or so as
SNL's get more into direct investments
and the bank's get more into home loans
about 40 years ago right after the Great
Depression the government set up
a federal system of savings and loans
basically to save the homes of people
who are being foreclosed through the
collapse of the banking system and for
40 years the idea was that the SNL's
would be targeted on home mortgages that
they would allow people to buy their
homes and they were given a great deal
of legal protection to encourage that
it's only since they got into a an
interest rate crunch in the late 70s and
began to lose money hand-over-fist
that that mission was diluted and since
that's occurred there really do seem to
be converging on the roles of banks and
it may well be that in another decade
the whole separate structure is
collapsed into one water hill florida
good morning good morning I'm very
pleased with c-span having a guest like
this on because the my way of thinking
that this is all the greatest scandals
that's ever hit America makes the teapot
dome and Watergate and iran-contra look
like peanuts compared to what actually
are both parties have engaging one of
the most demeaning things that our
taxpayers of America what I'd like to
ask our guest though is that there this
new Savings and Loan bill which is
supposed to bring them out it's just
another political fix because now in
Texas Strauss who set up one of the
savings and loans for a big forum there
in bankruptcy and he's that is a on
every Presidential Commission head of
the Democratic Party and he set up the
savings along Lincoln I believe it was
and now he's getting three million
dollars a year to take care of the
property that he conned the savings
alone into accepting as a viable
mortgage now if this is going to
continue but we'll never get out of this
thing and there's no one blowing the
horn on this so I just hope you continue
with your work thank you to call Porter
I've got to agree with that and I think
well what he just mentioned about Texas
is well worth looking into but there's
even talk now that we're going to need a
second bailout a bailout of the bailout
because the funds aren't sufficient and
because a lot of the pressures that led
to the crisis in the first place are
still there Deposit Insurance for
instance is still basically an unlimited
program how much is this going to cost
oh I'd say easily about 300 billion and
Counting going higher and I agree that
this is a serious scandal as we've ever
had in our country because it affects
every single one of us and it's $12,000
every man woman and child in the country
and if you have three kids and a wife
well that's 7,000 right out of your
pocket Carlsbad New Mexico good morning
good morning try to have I am a
stockholder in the saviour's 1
Association very minor stockholder who
is lost his investment and I have a
question what is your estimate of the
percentage of losses in the savings
loans due to fraud are due to pur
investments are to the economy in the
state's that has gone sour and loss of
the money from the savings loans due to
those investments there in urban studies
surveys have failed SNL's and they have
found this is unsetting a General
Accounting Office report that only 6% of
the failures could be attributed solely
to the economy the extent of fraud in
causing the losses is absolutely
staggering if you define it broadly
include bad management insider dealing
you're talking 80 90 percent of the
cause of the failure in fact when you
talk about the regional economy the S&L
is the the bad investments
reach such a magnitude that that may
well be responsible for some of the
economic downturn we're seeing in states
like Texas and Arizona port st. Lucie
Florida good morning good morning
gentlemen mr. Adams now when in fact did
a regulation begin I believe it's
our 279 and secondly one more question
isn't it true that Congress has recently
amended the RICO Act and in so doing is
made it difficult if not impossible to
recover assets squirreled away in Swiss
banks etc by relatives principles and
that the in effect we aren't really
going to be able to follow the paper
trail
and I understand that it was about two
weeks ago that Congress very quietly but
wrote into law amendments to the RICO
Act isn't this organized crime sir well
I think the RICO is something we should
watch very carefully the there have been
changes in Rico but I understand that
there was some effort to exclude the
savings and loan prosecutions from the
amendments so that those who continue in
full effect but these are very difficult
prosecutions and as you point out a lot
of the of the money has been squirreled
away has been rattled and a lot of it
probably has gone overseas to Swiss bank
accounts the prosecutors are finding
very difficult to track the money trail
in fact one case they were successful
only because the owner of this S&L had
written a note to himself saying
reminding himself to put money in Swiss
bank account and when they closed the
SML they found the note on his desk and
they were able to catch him at the
airport he was about to leave the
country
Phoenix good morning good morning right
ahead yes I wanted to bring to mr.
Adams's attention the situation here
with senators beacon Feeney the hundred
million dollar loans advanced to a
company
real estate company called are a home
which involves Deakin Sini's teas
fundraiser cats and his campaign manager
for three years over and these loans
this company was loaned a hundred
million dollars and their net worst was
about two million they had a hundred
million in in debts and a hundred and
two million in assets and yet they were
alone two hundred million
and 30 million of it was completely
unsecured and Lincoln thrift used these
transactions to show profits on their
books that made certain years
I'm not specific about it looked like
they had made 25 million dollars profit
and so on
and in one of the grower land deals a
Lincoln thrift sold a half half of it
they originally had 2,600 acres which
they paid twenty one point five million
four and a year later they sold it to RA
homes for twenty five million dollars
and so made it she could show a twenty
five million dollar profit in one year
Phoenix do you have a question for us
this morning well yes the question is
that when is this going to be focused on
so that we know that this is the single
single biggest senatorial scandal of
them all and this explains senators
Deacon Feeney's great great effort to
help feeding thanks for the call Phoenix
yeah I think that you bring up an
excellent point which is that we focus
we've been focusing on the campaign
contributions so far but there are
hundreds of ways for an S & L to buy
influence and Lincoln apparently was
very aggressive in deals like this I
these have to be brought out in the open
and I think there's a lot more that
really hasn't been uncovered yet it
hasn't hasn't been discussed but as you
say the this kind of manipulation
it really inflated Lincoln's books and
I've seen a one report that Kenneth
Leventhal report which said that Lincoln
was a loss from day one and that it was
kept the only reason it showed a profit
at all was because of these
manipulations they count a hundred and
fifty million dollars worth of fraud and
these are the subject of several suits
but I don't think I have not seen the
reporting on this that it deserves
you're right in this morning's New York
Times
line storm of Nathaniel nation Congress
fingers began to point he quotes
representative Richard layman a
California Democrat is saying I don't
think anyone is real comfortable with
getting sucked into this the public sees
your name in the newspaper next to a
savings and loan and thinks you've done
something wrong these fellows done
anything wrong I think so
I think they betrayed the public trust
they may not have violated the rules of
Congress
those are lacks enough I and it may be
difficult to prove a case against them
it's been difficult to prove a criminal
case against some of the owners of these
SNL's but in in terms of their their
role which should be protecting the
public interest I think they've clearly
betrayed their their duty not Vernon New
York good morning good morning said good
morning James Adam I want to
congratulate you for doing the great
public service job disables that World
War two and I think our country is in a
quagmire it's a disgrace to see mr.
Ronald Reagan go to Japan and the mess
were in the biggest in the history of
America I didn't have to hear you to say
it's going to be over three three
hundred billion dollars you take the
House of Representatives and you take
the United States Senate and I've been
in politics for years there's an old
saying Jimmy hyzer used to be the leader
in New York he said the only difference
between the Republicans and the
Democrats Republicans a steal and a
pocket at the Democrats they steal in it
and they divide it the reason we have
SNL in the HUD scandal is very simple
take a look at our last election in New
York City what are the greatest men that
ever ran for public office we're off
Giuliani a fearless prosecutor but what
after Wall Street who went after all up
came within a hair of winning this
election from a clubhouse politician
like Koch
what we have to do in this great country
of ours is we need more regulation is
ever-watchful of our politicians both
Democrats and Republicans and you mr.
Adams deeds help and soda c-span because
channel 4 channel 2 a number all
controlled by some of the one of the
hundred richest families in America
thanks for the call Mount Vernon New
York got your point this morning
is he talks about regulation is there a
moving Congress now away from the the
era of deregulation we're moving back
now not only in this area but in other
areas well there's a lot of talk like
that it may well be a mistake I think
that they are confusing it well once
again confusing regulation with
supervision
we always need supervision I think
regulation in terms of impact on the
market may well wind up hurting the
consumer but the consumer has to be
protected when he doesn't have access to
the information about the condition of
banks and SNL's San Diego good morning
good morning I have a question are there
people who feel that because of SNL and
hood that we should ask Congress to
limit their time and officeholders like
we have for the president thank San
Diego I've heard that suggestion I'm not
sure that's the right approach I think
that I think their offices should be
limited by the voters not necessarily by
laws or constitutional amendments but
when you look at the turnover in the
last Congress 98 percent of the
incumbents in the house were re-elected
and I think that has opened the door
toward this kind of activity especially
since they have realized that if you
have enough money to buy the right
technology you can practically reinsure
your re-election over and over and over
again that's what the voters should be
focusing on addison texas good morning
texas you with us yes go ahead please
okay first thing I'd like to say is up
in observation the Banking Committee
that is investigating a Lincoln why why
don't we have virtually all the
lightweights in Congress instead of
doing this with the committee seemingly
in disarray so to speak that doesn't
even come close to comparing to the
people and the manner in which the
iran-contra are all the way back to the
big deal about the Nixon and so forth
we have lightweights on there like to
get Kennedy and not seeming to get
focused in together with the media is
there printing a little articles and so
forth but it doesn't seem like any in
there
the business relative committee wonder
respond today thanks Texas well one
reason the committee is divided is that
a lot of the members are embarrassed by
this investigation
congresswoman Nancy Pelosi from
California for instance has been a
staunch ally of Senator Cranston for
years he saw Frank annunzio trying to
cover himself in the last hearings last
Tuesday and you saw some members of the
committee trying to break down the
witness at the time ed gray because
their friends in the Senate were being
threatened I think the what we're really
saying is basically a one-man show or
two-man show
that's Henry Gonzalez and Jim leach who
are the ones who have the grasp of it I
think the committee does have good staff
and it knows where it's going and is
going to do a good job but it's not the
most impressive body in Congress in fact
it's only an accident of history that so
we have Gonzalez in charge and doing
this otherwise I think there would be
nothing the the article in New York
Times about encounter with the headline
in Congress fingers began to point
nathaniel nash reports that some of the
congressional resentment is directed at
Banking Committee chairman Henry
Gonzalez who's displayed unexpected
doggedness in pursuing the Lincoln
failure felt a little bit about Henry
Gonzalez well I can see why Congress is
annoyed with him because he has really
opened a can of worms and he's one of
the few people in the institution who I
think has the the courage and the
honesty to do this he's a congressman
from San Antonio I followed his career
for years of for a long time he was kind
of shunted aside in the affairs of the
house and not regarded as with the
seriousness that he's commanding now
he's a one of the I think the first
Hispanic or one of the first Hispanic
members of Congress and very conscious
of his role as a defender of the of the
underdog
he's declined to take large campaign
contributions from any special interest
he doesn't really need it to be
reelected in San Antonio and I think
he's taken this opportunity one to open
up a scandal which he understands and
which has been festering for years I and
and really to carry on the populist
tradition of
people like Wright Patman the previous
who is the chairman many years ago Fort
Walton Beach Florida good morning yes
good morning I feel like the fellow that
called the caller before less
expectorant ah I myself want to thank
mr. Adams I just picked up a DAV
magazine here just recently and saw
where they're going to cut back benefits
to six hundred twenty thousand veterans
disabled veterans and although it's not
because of the SFL think this adds to it
and there's many different ways that our
people are being sucked away of money
from the people and given to different
politicians are taken by different
politicians and different ways I think
we ought to limit our politicians that
may be four years in Congress or in the
Senate or whatever something's got to be
done our senior citizens need money for
medical care and we're giving money away
to foreign countries like Israel and
Egypt five billion dollars a year now
we're going to be making funds for of
the countries like Poland and what have
you and at the same time we're taking
benefits from our senior citizens and
disabled veterans or not I just think
something's got to be done and mr. Adams
is on the right trail I want to thank
Thank You thanks Florida well I think
really the most vicious part of the SNL
crisis is we have 300 billion dollars
being sucked out of the federal budget
taken away from necessary social
programs and being wasted this is this
is a dead waste a dead loss we have
lines open for our callers on the west
coast and our next call is from Los
Angeles good morning morning I'm I have
a question about pension plan money in
the future a comment was made to be by a
colleague by the way I'm a physician
that
when it's my time to retire we're going
to be the ones that are going to have to
pay for all the debt that's being
accumulated now in the form of much
higher taxes and their pension plan if
you're Carmen thanks Los Angeles effect
on pension plans well I think everything
is going to everything is going to be
impacted pension plans as well as
industry costs like bank fees the money
is going to come from somewhere and and
we have bonds floated for 30 30 years
we're going to be paying off this crisis
for well into the 21st century and here
right it's going to be around when when
I retire while Illinois I good morning
you asked over the senator does anything
to do with the banks not cashing people
I'm a Czech buyer to this the banks were
able to blow someone's check for all 15
to 30 days to gain interest rates now if
you go in they want cash for employment
checks they they will tell you can
deposit for three days or so but they
won't die like the kashyap and I was
wondering what connection that is as far
as regulation is concerned well I think
everything is related one of the ways
that we are paying for this loss is out
of reduced service from our banks higher
fees when we bounced a check is it's $20
a check at least and you pay service
fees on your bank balance when it's
below a certain amount and and things
like refusing to cash checks I think the
services the banks have provided are
being reduced because they have to pay
the increased premiums to the insurance
funds to make up for the loss and and
we're paying directly as as the the
entries and consumer Talladega Alabama
good morning good morning well I'm going
to rest until now a couple of questions
are one uh a veteran that takes care of
a child is not here and uh he dies and
they go get his pension it's in the
government's into child to school takes
care of up to 18 and sent him to school
tisha then it's County legitimate but
after Veterans name took him since
baby knows all comes along after the boy
dies he wants to collect he never never
even not City with the child's father
for anything another man took work that
seems I have written the government off
to me look like heels to cover call them
here is it to cover took care of it
means think about that and then I won't
ask you to borrow a letter here it's uh
from the president I heard little cup
which will have one of these he says it
was not nominated by the Executive
Committee which include Republican
members of the United States Senate the
President Bush to serve as member the
judge was Republic Republican president
a task force and a home down here we
talked about the lot don't cry some
ridiculous I will read the whole
everything okay thank you ask me $420
don't you think this is a way of getting
on a campaign money there thank you okay
thanks for the call Alabama quick
comment I think I've gotten about five
or six of those letters it's a it's
annoying and uh I don't know what to say
about the first case but though I think
all our problems in dealing with the
federal government are going to be made
worse by by the situation Scottsdale
Arizona good morning good morning
I'd like to ask mr. Adams accounting is
supposed to be a precise science uh now
in addition to the government auditors
in addition to a Gao and the incident in
the the entities like that in we had the
public auditors come in once a year I
mean very respected firms like Arthur
Andersen a to show us and they find
their balance sheets showing that
everything was alright how is this
possible well I can only say that the
first person to take the Fifth Amendment
before the Gonzalez committee was the
accountant for Lincoln Savings and Loan
and I think we're uncovering a can of
worms in the accounting industry as well
as everything else this is a fellow who
signed a clean bill of health for
Lincoln and three months later took a
job at Lincoln with a salary of nine
hundred thousand dollars a year
I wonder he took the fifth
Kansas City Missouri good morning good
morning
I was wondering yet I don't really
understand too much about how they bail
out work but it sounds to me like
they're taking money that they don't
even have I mean I mean you know we
don't have enough malice paper things
and then they're paying something out so
because a bunch of crooks took a bunch
Molly and I can't understand how we can
do that I I mean there's many people
needs help and everything that he's
using it I mean to bail them out I mean
if you go bankrupt or something if I go
bankrupt
nobody's gonna bail me out you know so I
can understand how they can do that
and one more thing I want to ask you
about I heard remark the other day that
if they didn't get you know their real
fast in time you know that government
check and everything would be held up
Social Security checks all that well I
am supposed to do is completely
different all myself has nothing to do
with the government pardon
thanks for the call Kansas City quick
comment about the the insurance of
deposits well one thing when we're
talking about a bailout actually well
the money is going to is to the
depositors because of the deposit
insurance the owners we heard from a
stockholder who lost his money the
owners are being wiped out as they
deserve to be but the enormous expense
of the bailout comes from this
open-ended deposit insurance program
which has really been turned away from
its original purpose of protecting the
savings of the small individuals into
another Wall Street investment vehicle I
it's turned into another ripoff the the
phrase that used sometimes in your book
is about the the thrift high fliers how
how did these these folks fly what were
some of the most flagrant examples you
saw them using this this money in ways
well one favorite character is this
fellow Don Dixon in Dallas who is very
close to Tony Coelho and Jim Wright who
used his depositors money to buy a fleet
of antique automobiles he collected
antique automobiles
he financed his extravagant tours of
three-star restaurants and France he had
a five million dollar collection of
Western art a lot of which disappeared
when the thrift was taken over by the
government and generally had an
extremely lavish lifestyle which seems
to be a common feature for many of these
people as if they realize they have five
years to spend the money and they better
spend it now because eventually they're
going to get caught San Diego good
morning morning I think people are
forgetting that the public voted for
Ronald Reagan who said he was going to
get the the federal government off the
backs of all the entrepreneurs and
that's why most of this happens
Edwin Gray said the other day he didn't
follow anything that the congressmen or
senators wanted him to do he followed
what the Management and Budget Office
said and what the Donald Regan said he
could have C could have closed these
places down but he didn't that's all I
have to thank thanks San Diego well he
couldn't close them down because he did
not have the money and he did not have
the money to close these down because
Congress would not give it to him
I think we were overlooking a certain
problem which is that the insurance fund
for the SNL's was bankrupt as of 1985
when gray went to Congress to get
authorization to raise more money they
refused to give it to him because they
were protecting the SNL's that were
owned by the crooks who were their large
contributors that's that's a factor
that's been somewhat forgotten and all
this talk about the five senators New
York City good morning yes good morning
I again want to thank c-span for
carrying the hearings of the Banking
Committee Montek we all should give us
support to congressman Gonzalez to keep
up his tenacity you can just feel the
tension and the animosity there but I
want to bring one thing that I want to
be sure that I understood correctly
during the hearings that one of the
examiners in the last days of the
Lincoln when it was coming to the public
notice that Keating started divesting
huge amounts of money and someone to
Cranston
but there was also a Panama connection
that Noriega has been sort of a banking
system that's comparable to what's going
on in Switzerland could you address that
did I understand that correctly you did
and it's a fascinating new revelation
that that has come out a Panama has a
bank secrecy that exceeds that of
Switzerland and they use the dollar as a
currency so it's become a an
international center for all sorts of
strange financial doings it's the
International Centre for drug money
laundering for instance and a lot of
banks have branches in Panama also for
legitimate reasons for their business
deals in Latin America but for a an SNL
in California to have a Panamanian
subsidiary as it turned out heating did
raises a lot of questions I mean what
was he using it for Fort Pierce Florida
good morning for tea with us now it's
just Philadelphia I'm sorry go right
ahead place uh how many of these people
running these SNL's made more than
eighty nine thousand five hundred
dollars it seems to be that if you you
only make that much you need more to buy
morality at least that's what all our
congressman is saying I I think Slade
Gordon at the eastern airline hearing
had the right tact when he he tried to
hat coerce the CEO of Exxon by saying
when the Japanese have a scandal they
all retire I don't know why all our
congressmen don't be tired thanks for
the call Philadelphia no I think that's
a legitimate question and certainly the
the people who are running these SNL's
made far more than eighty nine thousand
more like eight hundred thousand and up
now we'll go to Fort Pierce Florida good
morning good morning I'm wondering about
a possible solution
suppose that in we elected our senators
and our representatives for a six year
period and never could they be reelected
then would they possibly do what's best
for the country and do everything they
could for the country
for one year and they wouldn't have to
worry about thinking about constituents
and doing what's best to be reelected
thanks for the call Florida well I I
think we have to take responsibility for
the system as it stands now ultimately
it's the voters who decide whether
whether these people stay in office or
not and we have to pay a lot more
attention and demand a lot more
information about their dealings with
these businessmen underneath the title
of your book the big fix is a second
smaller title how an unholy alliance of
politics and money destroyed America's
banking system is the system beyond
repair or is it just a matter of money
if there's enough money it will be fixed
I think there are some real structural
defects and the seeds of the next crisis
are already present in this one we
haven't done anything about Deposit
Insurance to make sure that it's
targeted on the people who really need
it that's still an open-ended program
and we certainly haven't done anything
about the system in Congress were
campaign contributions by access and the
public interest is forgotten st. Helens
Oregon good morning yeah hello
right ahead yes I've been amazed at the
amount of corruption on both sides of
the parties you know I've got a little
Vince omneya staying up watching these
hearings and it's just the web is so
huge I took all my money I've had all
the banks and invest in myself from
savings alone I'm sure as Paula while
other people have done the same and I'm
just wondering if any of these people
are going to end up losing their jobs
like some I think some of the federal
employees some of the federal employees
Jed look the other way I don't I don't
think that they should be working no
more and I think that the politicians
that's got their hands in everybody's
pockets I think a few of them should
like previous car said resign ix I'm not
putting no money and no savings and
loans or anything until I see some major
prosecutions and changes you think
anybody will get go to jail friends
Thanks Oregon well I certainly hope so I
think people do deserve to go to jail
and I think the criminal investigations
deserve to go into the federal
bureaucracy and into the Congress but as
you point out this is a bipartisan thing
oh the both sides of the aisle have been
implicated and I think both sides should
be investigated in partially at one
point in your book you say that you say
Washington is so degenerate that many
elected officials don't know they're
corrupt expand on that a little bit well
I think that's one of the most shocking
things I had an interview with Senator
McCain who is I think an honorable and
decent man who asked me with great
indignation how I dare say that he had
done anything improper in this meeting
with Keating he just doesn't get the
point that this is improper influence
this is the equivalent of interfering in
a court trial of trying to fix a judge
because the man they called in to me
with them at Grey was in the position of
a judge in a legal proceeding against
this SNL but these people have so lost
their moral standards that they don't
really understand what's going what's
going wrong Fort Myers Florida good
morning hi I haven't heard you address
something that's been puzzling me for
quite a while I recall hearings right
after the first of the year when
congressman Gonzalez was really angry at
Danny walling he his name is for having
what he called a fire sale of a SNL's I
guess they were and other assets mostly
for tax purposes but according to what I
recall about it he sold these places uh
how this was done I don't really
understand but he sold them for you know
pennies on the dollar and they were
going to be able to turn around and sell
them to other people for tax credits I
mean the whole thing was such a ripoff I
remember he was so angry and I've never
read anything about it I never hear
anybody address it could you help me out
sure no I think that's that's right the
whole area has been overlooked because
so much else has happened since but up
till early this year the government did
not have the money to go in and close
down an SNL properly and pay off the
depositors so they resorted to all sorts
of fancy accounting gimmickry and and
fire sales to try to put the really
corrupt and the hopeless SNL's in the
hands of decent management and I don't
think that really worked but up until
December 1 this tax benefit that you
referred to was closed off there was a
wave of bailouts in Texas and now a lot
of the institutions that were supposedly
the rescuers are now have to be rescued
Las Vegas good morning good morning I
like to get this television down and
wonder if you've ever noticed that every
time a bunch of sleaze comes up up pop
all the people from Texas there's Bush
Baker right Lorenzo Tower and on and a
hunt is it and then the 50s until they
go bad he's like Texas is in old crime
in the country but another thing I when
I asked you it's why would anyone ever
again
put a nickel in any Savings and Loan
thanks for the call Las Vegas what's it
going to take to restore confidence well
I do want to say it's not just Texas in
fact one of the heroes so it is from
Texas Henry Gonzalez and we've had
crooked situations in Connecticut or I
come from it's it's national but it is
going to take I think a real revulsion
and a real rethinking of the of ethical
standards in Congress to to bring this
thing under control
Chicago good morning good morning my
question has to do with a point that mr.
Adams had raised in an article of Reason
magazine about CEM the ability to keep
so much of this secret during the
investigations relative to the
questionable standing of SNL and I'm
wondering if in light of all of his
findings if it's realistic for us to
assume that we can have a government
agency regulate banks or insurance
companies or anything like this in the
future
this should be looked at very seriously
as a private organization rather than
having it under the auspices or if not a
private organization at least have the
responsibilities as in the insurance
industry relegated back to the states
for regulatory authority rather than by
such powerful men who could influence
things so powerfully that we result in
the 300 billion dollar scandal